DINO CHIESA: Welcome,
and thanks for joining.
I'm glad you're all here.
My name is Dino Chiesa.
I work for Google
on the Apigee team.
My role is to help customers
understand and use Apigee
to solve their
business problems.
Today, we're going to talk
about service mesh and API
management, and how T-Mobile
adopted both of these
to improve their capability
to deliver innovation
securely and at scale.
This isn't news,
enterprises are evolving
their monolithic
applications into
microservices architectures.
Modeling a system as a set of
interconnected microservices
helps organizations to build and
maintain complex, distributed
systems more easily.
The theory is small
grained services can
be independently developed,
versioned, deployed,
scaled, and updated, meaning a
more flexible, agile approach
as the system grows.
It's an attractive idea, and
service mesh infrastructure
has been built to
help manage these sets
of inter-cooperating
services, lightweight proxies,
like Linkerd or Envoy,
management tools built
on top of these.
These allow the services
to find each other,
communicate securely,
and scale elastically.
But no enterprise,
no matter how modern,
consists only of systems
built on microservices.
That's one category
in a portfolio,
which includes custom monoliths
and third-party SaaS systems.
Now, a service is only
useful if developers
can find it, get the credentials
required to connect to it,
and then build and run
an application using
those credentials.
For good hygiene, we've
got to manage and measure
all of that activity.
This is where API
management comes in.
It helps you manage
the APIs that are
shared outside of each domain.
And remember, sharing
could be across domains
within a company.
Now, I want to talk a little
bit about API management
and its enabling of
modernization, that transition
from monoliths to microservices.
One capability of an
API management system
is to intelligently route
requests from clients
to backend systems.
When you introduce
a new system, you
can use the API management
layer to migrate those requests.
This is a really common use
case among our customers.
The routing can be dependent on
any factor, and can be dynamic.
Client applications can
be completely unaware
that this is happening, and that
facilitates a phased migration
with control.
Apigee is API management,
and it's cross-cloud,
allowing you to manage APIs
across your entire portfolio--
your own data center, public
clouds, third-party SaaS,
wherever the service is run.
With that, now I'd like
to invite my friend
Terry to talk about T-Mobile's
modernization journey,
and how they used API
management and service
mesh as complementary
pieces of their foundation.
Terry?
TERRY WANG: Thank you, Dino.
Hi, my name is Terry Wang.
I work on API management and
service mesh in API center
for the enablement
team at T-Mobile.
I'm glad to be here.
First, I want to talk about
our API first journey.
To be honest, it's been quite
a journey for us at T-Mobile.
We introduced Apigee
six years ago,
to jump-start our API program.
Back then, we had very
few microservices, or even
RESTful services.
Majority of the
services were SOA based,
delivered by middleware
platforms or custom Java
applications.
We use Apigee gateway mainly
to transform the SOA payloads
into JSON to make them
easier for the UI application
to consume.
Four years ago,
T-Mobile embarked
on the digital
transformation journey
and made the API first strategy
as one of its main drivers.
We started to break down
monolithic into microservices.
We had tremendous growth, not
only in number of services,
but also in business agility.
It used to take months
to make changes.
Now, many apps are
releasing daily.
It's so rosy, right?
Yes, but we definitely
experienced the growing pain.
We still had multiple platforms,
languages, and libraries.
Security was still
difficult to implement,
and observability and
delivery were inconsistent.
That's when we started to
look into Istio service mesh.
We successfully deployed our
pilot services into production
last year.
Now, we're planning to
roll out in big waves,
in both our public
and private clouds.
Since our team
started two years ago,
we've been working on
building developer tools
to bootstrap API development in
every phase of the lifecycle.
We have [INAUDIBLE]
in design phase
to make sure the API design
standards are followed.
In development phase,
we provide teams
with Apigee proxy and
Istio mesh generators.
In build and
deployment phase, we
give domain teams
the CI/CD pipelines
with compliance checks.
These tools allow development
team to deploy their services
into Apigee and service
mesh in a secure
and [INAUDIBLE] manner.
In every step in the API
development lifecycle,
the events are logged.
Metadata is collected.
And they are searchable through
our API Explorer tool, where
both API consumers
and providers can
find the relative information
about their services quickly.
This improves our [? meantime ?]
to recovery when issues occur.
We're very proud
of these tools that
enable us at T-Mobile running
our API program at scale.
What really motivated us to
look into Istio service mesh?
Well, the shift left insecurity
strategy a couple of years ago.
We wanted to enforce strong
token authentication for all
the APIs with proper logging
and monitoring for any security
violations.
We created token
libraries for Java
and made it available to
the development teams.
It worked well in some degree.
We had hundreds of
services adopt the library.
However, there's still
thousands of APIs left
and many programming
languages to cover.
That got us into
Istio, which provides
security and granular metrics
we're looking for, and more,
out of the box.
The features such as circuit
breakers and security handling,
connection timeout and
retrying, and telemetries
are often handled by
development team in the code.
Depends on programming languages
and libraries, and project
timelines, sometimes.
These features were
implemented in different ways
and managed by different
tools that were inconsistent,
a big overhead for teams
to manage and operate.
With a service
mesh, these features
are offered at platform level.
Using standard policies, the
overhead for these events
features shifts from
developers to the service mesh.
It helps development teams
deliver product features
and deliver them faster
and more securely.
Service mesh and API management
solve two different problems.
Together, it transforms
your backend services
into APIs that are consumable
by internal and external
applications.
The service mesh
gives more details
to service clients about the
topology of the architecture,
the resilience mechanisms
they should implement,
and granular telemetry
they should collect,
as security flows
that participate.
All these implementation details
are provided to application
by Envoy cycle process.
With API management,
we're trying
to solve the problem
of when we wish
to expose existing APIs for
others to consume, how do we
track?
Who uses this API?
And enforce policies
about who's allowed
to use them, and establish
security flows to authenticate
authorized permissible use,
and build a catalog of services
that can be used at the design
time to promote API usage.
At T-Mobile, our
services are built
in different sizes and forms.
They are deployed in
various platforms,
in on-prem cloud
or public cloud.
API management layer allows us
to provide consistent influence
to the consumers and
lays the foundation
for effective governance.
API gateway and service
mesh architecture
is the paved road at
T-Mobile for API development.
Next, I'm going to demo
our Apigee proxy generator
and use your mesh
generator tools
that enable developers
to deliver services
faster with a strong security
by default. In this session,
I'm going to demo a
couple of generator tools
in our tool suite, Istio
config gen and Apigee ProxyGen.
The purpose of these generators
is to let developers quickly
get onto the platform and
take advantage of the platform
features right away without
spending too much time to learn
it, so that they can
focus more on developing
their domain-specific features.
This generator bundle, a
default set of features
often required to make
this service more secure
and follow the best practices
set forth by the company.
Definitely,
developers can always
add to their custom
policies and configurations
that meet their specific
requirements later.
Out of the box, the
default should already
provide 70% to 80%
of the features.
OK, let's get into it.
Let's look at the
Istio mesh gen first.
We always follow the
API first approach.
So the mesh config generator
is actually a microservice,
a RESTful service.
It will generate the Spring
Boot app, the Istio home charts,
and a default CI/CD pipeline.
And then we use a home chart
to deploy the configurations
into Istio clusters.
Let's look at more details
about the Istio config gen.
So this is the request object
for the generator service.
So you specify the
user information.
This is used for
adding team purposes.
And you specify type
of applications,
like Spring Boot or
some other types.
And where do you want to
store the generated artifacts?
If you want to generate
the microservice based
on the swagger by
default, you can
specify the swagger information,
and the Java-based class,
and some other informations.
And for Istio, right,
so you need to specify,
where is your cluster.
Where do you want to
deploy these apps to?
I really can change or add
other configurations later.
So one of the
features is required
is the security checkup
with the token validations.
This is required by any
services at any layer
to enforce a zero trust.
So these are the configurations.
And luckily, Istio still
provides this feature
by default. You just
need to configure it.
Let me run this service.
OK.
It will take a few seconds.
But you will see
a new folder will
be created in the repository.
Now, it's started generating.
And the Istio configuration
is stored at a common folder.
And these are the features
we bundled together
as a default set--
the authentications,
and the service entry,
and circuit breakers,
and a default
canary release pattern, and
HPA, and some other routings.
I want to get specifically,
into the authentication
configuration.
So we enable MTLS and
get up token validations.
So this is to make the
service more secure.
And you don't need to
implement the libraries
at the code-level.
So we also generate a
default CI/CD pipeline,
which allows you to deploy your
configurations into the cluster
more easily.
So the pipeline will
build the Java app
and push the container
image into the registry,
and do the static
code scan, and run
the default setup of
unit test, and finally,
deploy into the cluster.
And you can customize
this as all you want.
And the default should
work for most of the teams.
OK.
So I've generated one
yesterday to save time,
because the whole process
running through the CI/CD
pipeline will take
about seven minutes.
Now, you can see everything
is running green.
It's deployed into
the Istio cluster,
which is running up here.
Now, I can launch a test
to verify the features.
So if I don't have the bearer
token and I should 401.
Yes, it's unauthorized, right.
So if I include
valid bearer token,
now it's getting through.
However, my service, since it's
not implemented, what rule 501.
So the other one I want to test
is that and exclude the house
check path, right.
So without a token, it
should work just fine.
So let me verify that.
Yes, I don't have
any bearer tokens.
And I'm getting
a valid response.
OK, so this is how easy
it is to adopt the Istio--
the features, and
you can quickly
deploy your microservice
into the cluster.
Secondly, I want to demo
the Apigee ProxyGen.
Just from a swagger
file, and you
can specify the Apigee proxy
names and some other vaulting
rules, and will generate
a default set of policies.
And then you can deploy it
into any Apigee environment.
Whether or not it's SaaS, or
on-prem, it doesn't matter.
So with this
approach, we achieved
end-to-end connectivity
and security.
So let me show the
generator a little bit.
Just to save time, I already
built this configuration
already.
And everything is
based on this swagger.
And given the swagger will have
the default values for you,
you specify where do you want
to store the generated project,
and how to route to targets,
and what the project information
does for tracking as well.
And finally, so you can submit,
will generate a Apigee CI/CD
pipeline for you.
So over here, it generated
the proxy endpoint.
It generated the
target endpoints.
And then pipeline generated.
And then we'll do quite a
few compliance of checks,
and the authentication
authorization checks,
and threat protection checks.
And loggings, we definitely
need, and also the quota
and the SpikeArrest
for traffic policies.
And then you can just deploy
to any environment you want.
So you can customize this
to add more as you wish.
So I want to show you
what the policies looks
like when it deploy into
the Apigee environment.
So you can see that
by default, we'll
use the shared flow for
many of these policies.
And there's a default set
of policies for PreFlow
and another for set of policies
for Post Client, PostFlow.
And then there is
logging policies
in the Post Client flow.
So without you knowing
anything about Apigee,
you are able to just expose
your service on the Apigee
and expose to other
teams to consume.
Now, let's look at the
end-to-end testing.
So I do have this
service up here.
This is configured,
exposed through the Apigee,
and connect to the service
I just deployed in the Istio
environment.
So without the token,
I should get 401.
So this is from Apigee,
right, so not allowing
to pass to the backend at all.
There's a security protection.
If I do have the
[? joe ?] token,
I'm passing through
Apigee layer and getting
into the Istio service mesh.
And I'm getting the
501 not implemented,
which is the correct response.
So if I give the
wrong token, I'm
getting a more generic message.
So this is when you
expose through Apigee
and you're getting
more unified error
messages for all these services
exposed through Apigee.
So the third feature I want to
demo is our API Explorer tool.
So we collect all
the informations,
every step of the process,
including the generator,
including the deployment.
From the API Explorer, you
can get all those informations
from swagger specification,
to where it deployed,
and who's consuming,
and who owns this,
and what's the revision history.
So one of the things
I do want to show
is the telemetry, right.
So this is the Apigee proxy
I deployed today by me.
And I want to see the metrics.
Since I deployed yesterday,
I did some testings today.
So it shows all the
details about this service,
and shows how it performs,
and what error I can get.
This is the end of my
demo, which shows you
how to use the generators to
deploy your service into Istio
and expose through Apigee.
And you're getting a default
set of features and also
the telemetries you're getting.
Thank you very much.
DINO CHIESA: Thanks
for that, Terry.
It's super interesting
to learn about T-Mobile's
journey towards
greater flexibility
and agility in
their systems, which
brings me to the last thing I'd
like to mention, Apigee hybrid.
When customers use the
Apigee SaaS gateway, which
runs in the Google Cloud, the
connection from the client,
to the gateway, to
the upstream service
can span multiple
public networks.
With Apigee hybrid, you can run
at Apigee gateway as co-located
with your workloads.
This flexibility
means you can avoid
crossing network boundaries,
while still enjoying
seeing great Apigee capability.
So consider that if you
need that capability.
Finally, I'd like to summarize.
A couple of things
we learned today,
API management complements
microservices architectures.
Second, T-Mobile's
journey combines
API management and service
mesh with processes and tooling
to produce a platform on which
T-Mobile developers build
the future.
And finally, Apigee hybrid
provides even more flexibility
for those who need it.
Both Terry and I thank you
for watching this session.
To continue the
conversation, I've
set up some expert
one-on-one sessions
over the next couple of weeks.
We will be answering
your questions in the Q&A
section for the session also.
Thanks again.